over the last couple of years India's
most underprivileged citizens have taken
to the streets in thousands to protest
violence government policies and to
demand more rights and hundreds of
millions of people from the nation's
lowest caste will be a force to be
reckoned with when they head to the
polls to vote in national elections that
are due by May this is your Bloomberg
quick take on lower caste political
power
Hindus which make up 80% of modern India
were traditionally split into four
hierarchical groups the lowest of all
Dalits now form a quarter of the
population about 16 percent of all
voters there is a lot of discontent
especially amongst the talents there is
discontent among minorities and even as
far as the Hindus majority is concerned
to the upper caste or urban people one
hopeful to replace Narendra Modi as
Prime Minister is my OOTD a former Delhi
slum native who has been elected chief
minister of India's most populous state
of Uttar Pradesh four times her party
Bahujan Samaj vows to end caste
discrimination and build a society based
on equality and fairness she has
followers across states in India and
even if she wins say one or two seats in
every state even if she can't for you
know she she can be the kingmaker at
worst at best she could stand a good
chance of being the consensus candidate
for the other side laws against caste
discrimination were adopted seven
decades ago and with some exceptions
caste remains a major factor in
determining how people earn a living and
whom they marry especially in the small
towns and villages where around 70
percent of Indians live so far Modi has
his has been a very interesting
government simply because this is the
first time in three decades that we'd
had a leader come with this kind of
majority Modi wrote a wave of
dissatisfaction and emphasised his own
modest background to take power in 2014
but his BJP party has developed a
potentially problematic reputation as
far as dollar voters are concerned under
Modi's party the party and the party is
traditionally Bin's
has always been seen at the base of the
half what we called upper castes it
so basically the more privileged the
more land owning and of course business
only to us despite living in a
stratified society where circumstances
of birth to find a large part of what
the future will hold voters in the
world's largest democracy will soon be
hitting the polls as equals each
political party will tailor its message
with that in mind
[Music]
you